i would have never thought three or four
years ago that we'd have the
conversations we're having today that a
country could change as fast as america
has
i knew when i served in congress that i
served with members that were socialists
that embraced the policies and their
ways of life but they never would have
admitted it publicly and now look what's
happened they're openly holding press
conferences and embracing socialist and
marxist
platforms and programs for the united
states of america so if people who think
that well you know this is just another
episode like we saw in the 70s
you know yes we've been through
challenging times in the past some of
them
traits are familiar some of the riots
and the violence you know we we can
remember in our history where we've seen
that before but this is different
because they are trying to remake
america and they're getting more
traction than they've ever gotten before
so so what do we do what do we do i mean
biden said it himself a couple of months
ago food shortages you know i think uh
was that the economist or one of the
major magazines the food shortages are
coming world economic forum worrying
about uh talking about it bill gates is
now the largest farm land owner in the
united states i mean what what do you do
as as a governor of a state what do you
do well first of all i have to be honest
and talk about it this this
administration's not talking about
solving the problem
uh and in fact they're facilitating
foreign countries coming in and buying
up our systems in our land
so the administration being honest and
recognizing it as is a real challenge
and solving it would be important
cutting regulations to allow more of our
american businesses to to buy back these
facilities to be in production
agriculture to grow our own food is
important right now they're attacking
our farmers and ranchers and they're
penalizing them and putting heavy
regulations on them that don't allow
people to work on their land don't allow
their children to participate in the
business at all and in south dakota here
we've been aggressive in cutting back
regulations we've also been aggressive
in building our own processing plants
i've given millions and millions of
grants to people who want to build a
meatpacking plant or expand a facility
that would put value-added food on the
table for families here so that we
control our own destiny and that many
many of these producers can control
their own supply chain to get it right
to the customer we're bypassing a lot of
these big corporations that that own the
systems that are stealing the profits
away from those that are actually
growing the food and making sure we're
putting that control back in the hands
of the consumer who needs to put that
food on the table
what do you make of this administration
when it comes to everything we've talked
about here do you believe that it's
ineptitude or do you think that this is
intentional everything that's happening
right now
well
you know there's it's there's been a a
year and a half here where i thought you
know this guy's like the george costanza
of government like his
every instinct he makes is just wrong if
he would wake up in the morning yes he
should it just so but i i believe now
that meant much of this is intentional
that there's no way that somebody is
making decisions like this that truly
loves america um he is crippling our
country and and you can't possibly be
making these kinds of decisions
and have it just be a mistake so there's
an agenda here to control people
and it's been in place for a period of
time i'm not going to say it's coming
straight out of joe biden i think most
of the time he's not even aware of
what's going on necessarily but he's
being controlled
by by people who definitely do not want
a republic to continue in this country i
would have never thought three or four
years ago that we'd have the
conversations we're having today that a
country could change as fast as america
has i knew when i served in congress
that i served with members that were
socialists that embraced the policies
and their ways of life but they never
would have admitted it publicly and now
look what's happened they're openly
holding press conferences and embracing
socialist and marxist
platforms and programs for the united
states of america so
if people who think that well you know
this is just another
episode like we saw in the 70s you know
yes we've been through challenging times
in the past some of them
traits are familiar some of the riots
and the violence you know we we can
remember in our history where we've seen
that before but this is different
because they are trying to remake
america and they're getting more
traction than they've ever gotten before
speaking of that did you guys have any
of the the crazy riots that we saw
everywhere i mean it was usually in in
blue states and in blue cities but did
you have any of that during the summer
of tolerance or violence depending on
which way you look at well we had one
event that was planned a protest in our
largest city that was planned and i
pre-staged my national guard
to several different cities that night
and also my law enforcement officers and
then just told those i set up emergency
operations centers in each of these
cities too and coordinated everything
with the local law enforcement and
mayors in those towns but that evening
in sioux falls which is our largest city
i said as soon as we they throw the
first water bottle we're going in
and and so we did this crowd of
thousands of people
you know built throughout the night
moved throughout the city and when it
started to get violent we immediately
moved in and shut it down and said we
weren't going to stand peaceful protests
we will allow that's our constitutional
right but as soon as one thing happens
that that turns it into something very
different south dakota wouldn't stand
for it so it was remarkable what
happened
in south dakota because we didn't have
issues after after that period people
knew where we stood they knew we
protected law and order and even it was
kind of amazing because they had spread
out so far be in the city
uh you know having enough help was
incredibly important we saw citizens
come out
they were armed to help protect the
downtown streets we had
motorcycle groups come out and say we've
got these blocks the national guard can
move down to an area where there's more
of a threat and it was amazing to watch
people partner with our law enforcement
and with our guard members to keep
everybody safe
are you telling me that people who law
abidingly own weapons for their own
self-defense sometimes do good things
because that's not the meme out there
yeah no they did incredible things
during that period of time it was
remarkable to see even when president
trump
came to mount rushmore we had protests
throughout the black hills because at
that time
across the country people were tearing
down monuments they were tearing down
statutes and here
south dakota dared to have a celebration
in honor of the leaders on mount
rushmore and president trump and our
freedom
and
you know organized protesters those
seeking violence showed up and tried to
destroy the monument tried to create
problems that evening for the president
and we had
hundreds and hundreds of civilians
and again a lot of these motorcycle
groups came in rolled into these small
towns and kept law order for us so that
we could have a peaceful event where we
really did get to focus on america i'm
sure you hear it probably every day of
your life but i had never been to mount
rushmore until you know a year or two
ago when i went i mean it is truly i've
been to every monument and every you
know important place in the united
states it is the most breathtaking
absolutely incredible it's it's
mind-boggling that this thing was even
made it really is
it is it it at the time it was made the
incredible efforts that had to be done
and uh you know what's interesting is
just the need to protect it at this day
and age too you know we have
we have still security up there making
sure it's protected from protesters who
try to dump red paint down the faces or
try to
set off explosives to send a message
that's anti-american so
so it is a special treasure for us you
know people always get south and north
dakota confused and i'm constantly
saying to them north dakota got all the
oil
south dakota got mount rushmore and and
we're okay with that
so let's just go through a couple of the
other uh hot button issues that you've
been talking about uh obviously as we're
taping this we're holding it for a
couple days so it is possible that this
roe v wade decision because the supreme
court is making all these decisions this
week that are being released it may have
been already announced but it sounds
like roe v wade is going to be reversed
according to this leaked briefing that
we heard about a couple months ago
obviously your pro-life what do you
think the policy of south dakota is
going to be going forward will there be
any
room on that related to some of these
extreme cases etc etc
well right now in south dakota there are
no abortions being performed in our
state which is something i'm very proud
of you know i i ran for governor saying
i wanted to be the most pro-life
governor in the country
uh every action we've taken every bill
we've we've passed has been protecting
every single
innocent life and you know this decision
will be
monumental in the country south dakota
has a trigger law in place so as soon as
that decision comes forward abortions
will be illegal in the state of south
dakota except for in protection of the
life of the mother
i have already told my legislature that
we may have a need for a special session
to see what we can do to really partner
and help care for mothers that are in a
situation where they have a baby that
may need health care
that found themselves in a crisis
situation or facilitate better adoption
situations to connect people better make
sure that these children have the
opportunity to grow up in a home
where they're loved and cherished and
can be successful for many years to come
so
with that trigger law is important but
there also may be a need to make sure
that we clarify that the mothers aren't
the ones that we that should be punished
in this situation that it is those who
perform the abortions and knowingly
break the law doing it that need to be
punished if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell